[موسيقى]
مرحبا يتواجد النجم احمد مكي بجزء سابع من
مسلسل الكبير اوي هذا العام واللي يعتبر
من قبل البعض حلاوه رمضان كما يصف الجمهور
حيث ياتي بعمله خفيفه على المشاهدين
محافظا هذا العام على نفس مجموعه الممثلين
من العام الماضي مع العديد من كبار الضيوف
الشرف من الفنانين الجزء السابع من مسلسل
الكبير اويلين نقول انه في الحلقات الاولى
تضرر من السقف التوقعات المرتفع
للجمهور كان مستنيه لانه فعلا الجمهور
ارتبط به بشكل كبير في السنه اللي فاتت
لكن رجع التوازن تاني من بدايه حلقات نزول
الكبير ومربوحه الى القاهره وتعرضها للقطف
النجاح الكبير اللي حققه الجزء السادس من
المسلسل في الحقيقه سقف توقعاته الجمهور
وانت لما تقدم عمل قوي جدا وحقق نجاح كبير
جدا الجمهور بيبقى منتظر منك ان لم يكن
نفس النجاح فبيبقى ازيد اعتقد ان السنه دي
في شيء ما
لسه ما وصلش للجمهور نفس البريق ونفس
التالق ونفس النجاح ونفس الحواديت اللي
جوه المسلسل
طبيعي من يرى وجوب ايقاف
العملة واعتبار الجزء السابع هو الاخير
منه بينما هناك فئه اخرى ترى ان مكي لا
يستطيع الخروج من عباءه الكبير ولذلك لا
باس من المحافظه عليها لكن مع بعض
المخاطره في الافكار ما ينفعش نطلع اقول
المسلسل يوقف ممكن نقول لطائر المسلسل
يعني مثلا من اشهر المسلسلات الكوميدي في
العالم اتعمل عشر اجزاء برضو اتعمل عشر
اجزاء في مسلسلات كتير اتعملت اجزاء كتير
لو جيت شفت حلقه في مسلسل فريندز وجيت
شفتها وجيت شفت حلقه تانيه بعد موسمين هحس
ان في تغيير في كل حاجه يعني هحس ان
الاحداث بتتغير والشخصيات بتتغير
والافهاات بتتغير فانا مسلسل الكبير انا
لو اتفرجت على حلقه وجيت فركت كمان مسلمين
هحس ان هي نفس الاحداث لسه
جوني قاعد في المزاريطه يتكلم عربي بقى له
من 2011 تقريبا مسلسل او مش بالظبط لسه
هدرس بنفس الافات فهو الافيه حلاوه ان انت
ما تسمعوش قبل كده ما رايكم ان نتوقف
[موسيقى]
مع بعض
الشنطه فكره الفكره ما تموت
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات